Film Courage: Jeff, we've gotten to the tail
end of our work with the Story Engine cards
and the story that you've developed. How
can we take it to the finish line? I know
we weren't exactly sure certain details but we
fleshed out a lot of interesting options here.
Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist / Author / Founder
/ Consultant: right to to follow this
this trajectory which is basically we're working
with several of the seven tools that I teach
including the 36 dramatic situations and the
Enneagram but the main one we're focusing on
here is dilemma which consists of dilemma
crisis decision in action and resolution
so we've really solidified a dilemma to the
degree that we can we have some good strong
possibilities for Enneagram types which will
inform the story more as it the story progresses
the thing that I would do now is focus on crisis
which is the dilemma come to a head come to a make
or break point decision and action in the face
of Crisis and then the resolution of the dilemma
and once we have that then we've completed
one pass through one aspect of creating this
story by focusing mostly on dilemma which
is the way I start any story I kind of
grab the story and look at it through the
lens of dilemma because the protagonist
caught in a good strong dilemma amplifies
the dramatic power of the story it really
helps imbue the story with dramatic intensity
right from the beginning of creating it so that
you're building drama into the story from the
beginning of the process rather than inventing
a story and then trying to retrofit dramatic
tension into it so it sort of died in the wool
so The Next Step would be to focus on
the way in which this dilemma comes to
a critical juncture around the end of act
two and because we've only got a tentative
but pretty solid statement of dilemma
we've got a sense of personality types
the thing to do would be to focus
on dilemma and we don't have to
like we're not going to solve it comprehensively
because the dilemma is still tentative and fluid
but we want to bring crisis up to the level
that we have the dilemma at this point so
in this type of story what we're saying is that
so if I'm this robot which is one of the ways I
deal with dilemma as I put myself in
the position of the protagonist and
like it's unacceptable to do these morally
reprehensible things that the sun is
pushing me to participate in it's kind of like
the sun needs me to actuate it otherwise he'd just
go do it himself why would I be in the middle of
the mix probably because I'm wired into the whole
Factory and that kind of thing so he he needs me
to execute or to help execute probably because
I can do so many functions at once he could do
five of them I could do 40 billion in a second
it might take him all day to do five of them so
I'm required so it's unacceptable to participate
in this morally reprehensible thing that my ethics
programming kind of forbids me from doing and yet
and yet as a loyalist as a type six potentially
a loyalist isn't all about giving loyalty to
someone else they're also looking for loyalty
but the type six is one of the most basic things
about a type six is that they're contradictory
they can be both selfless and selfish they can be
you know generous and stingy they can be active
and passive there's all these different opposites
that they can embody in one person so if I'm this
like sentient robot of some kind not
necessarily sentient but a high-level AI
I can't participate in these
morally reprehensible things and yet
I can't let go of what the sun is
offering me which is a chance to be human
and I also have a need to like be loyal
type sixes can be like blindly loyal they're
always questioning but once they get beyond
their questioning and they really become loyal to
something they're also the type that can go down
with the ship they have trouble even if they see
they're wrong they're like I'm I'm all in anyway
so I can't contribute to the morally
reprehensible stuff but I can't let
go of this opportunity to become human
and I'm like sort of naturally wired to
defend the organization that I'm
part of and I'm starving to be human
so and there's this thing being put in motion
where this company not just a company this massive
Corporation that's probably similar to the
Tyrell Corporation potentially in certain ways
somewhere around the end of act two
it's about to be launched and
the this robot has to well the robot
is still wrestling with the dilemma
really enjoying the perks of kind of giddy
humanness going to the beach like doing stuff
he never did before and that presumes there's
like a humanoid type body but that it could
still be a robot but could go surfing girls are
interested can eat a hot dog can get sunburned
but it's still a robot but it's more
it's like Spock on catnip or whatever
and if the operating system is being
corrupted then at the point of crisis
the inner facilities of this automaton are
compromised to a dangerous level so that
right when this automaton needs his faculties the
most and it could totally be a she all of the any
of these it could all be women it could all be
anything all of the the faculties that are needed
most are the ones that are most missing at this
crucial juncture and see one of the things about
a crisis is that it's often the worst possible
things happening at the worst possible moment
and one of the aspects of the worst
possible things happening at the worst
possible moment can be that you're right
on the very precipice of total success
like why is everything falling apart right I'm an
inch away from undoing it is working I'm pulling
it off and it's all going to hell right on
the edge of success that can be a crisis
so the emerging humanoid aspects in the
personality of this automaton it can be like
it just got a girlfriend like it's like it's like
and it's going on a certain you know it's like
like why now like I'm they really think
I'm human and I feel like I'm human and
it's working and she likes me and I'm
a good Surfer and I you know it's like
it's way worse to give that up now than it
was 20 minutes earlier in the plot because I'm
like I'm addicted to being a person and it's
working or it's right on the edge of working
you know it might be that the sun has to I
got to adjust you a little bit more and then
you won't even remember you were used to be a
robot you'll really think you're this person
and all that type of stuff and he's like yes yes
I gotta have that and right at that point is when
things come to a head okay we're launching
tonight something happened we're moving the
launch date up so right now and we
were also talking about how if the
automaton in seeking guidance because the
giddiness of being human is really intoxicating
and like addicting but the kind of smoke alarm
that's going off in the brain of this automaton
like you're going to kill a billion people like
wake up what is going on like this is wrong
like that's screaming in there too and and that's
like the dilemma that this character has been
wrestling with throughout act two and as part of
that if he's reanimated the father who created
this whole company and the father is like able
to give him words of wisdom and encouragement
then that can be helping him and
it's possible that at the point of crisis I first
thought that the sun could kind of pull the plug
on this reanimation even if it's just an AI that
he's brought to a level of fruition that he can
communicate with it so have an intelligence so
like he's upgraded the AI aspects of the deceased
father so that it emulates his personality enough
that he can have like a real conversation with who
that person really was for him and like you can
really you you can make a decision and you're
not weak and you're a good person you know it's
saying all these things at first I thought the
sun might come along and kill the father again
if he's the one that killed the father earlier on
but it could even be worse than that like
what if the sun hears him getting words
of wisdom from the father and the son starts
laughing and like you fell for all that crap
and he like hits a button so that like the real
father comes out and the real father could be
a treacherous malignant monster just like the
sun and that's like who he really is and just
the disguise has come off so that for this poor
robot who's desperately struggling to navigate
the demands of his ethics his moral compass and
his incredible hunger to be human and to be loyal
and at that point he finds out that the founding
father really was a like sadistically vicious
horrible creature and that's why the sun turned
out that way even though he's great at hey he's
like everybody's best friend but he's like this
treacherous monster for that to hit this automaton
right at the worst possible moment then you not
only have the kind of mental breakdown going on
inside the robot as the faculties that he needs
the most at this moment are being corroded by
the Sun as the operating system is corrupted
more and more but that the one person who is
a Shining Light and a source of belief and
faith in everything is revealed to be by far
the worst monster in this entire universe it's
such a crushing shock it's like a back-breaking
taking away the one hope he had at the worst
possible moment and taking it away in the worst
possible way like you know the father ends up
laughing at him like you fell for all this you're
such a loser you don't know anything you know and
we made you like that you're a manipulable little
tin robot that does what we tell you and is very
happy about it loves everybody you know it's like
you know and like you're trash you're you served
your function thank you like get out which is
the Kinsmen slain unrecognized and discovery
of the dishonor of a loved one and disaster and
madness all of those things are constituting those
are some of the situations that are very active at
the point of crisis and so it's like you know the
rug isn't just jerked out from under this robot
at this key point but there's not even a floor
anymore he's like in free fall but he's got to
make a decision about this world crisis
that's in the throes of it's happening now
and maybe part of him is actuating it now like
performing the computations like he's been ordered
because he is just a robot or a puppet and yet
part of him is like screaming to try and stop it
and so the decision in action
is going to be something like
this robot makes a key decision that he's gonna
try to stop this and takes an action a just a
decision is nothing that's just like okay I'll
do that but you could still be laying in bed
saying that it's getting up and taking action so
it's decision and action in the face of crisis
and the decision in action are two sides of the
same coin it's one thing like you see your kid
about to get hit by a truck you're not going hmm I
better it's like you're already through the window
before you even have a chance to think about it
you know like you're throwing the frying pan and
the stool right through the window and you're
getting cut to and flying out there to rescue
your kid it's a decision and action in the face
of crisis so for this robot to take some kind of
stand to try to stop this thing which is already
in progress and looks like it's going to win
and the robot may not be able to stop its own
processes but it's gonna try to throw a monkey
wrench in there in fact the action would be to
throw a monkey wrench in there which may or may
not win but is no longer paralyzed like what am
I going to do when when I have to make a choice
now I've made a choice and I'm going to war and
it's the opening Salvo in the fight to the finish
and it's an attempt generally the beginning of
the fight to the finish is an honest attempt at
a killing blow like it's not only going to punch
you and then we're going to punch a whole bunch
more like I'm going to hit you so hard that you
die on impact that's the intent of the beginning
of the fight to the finish By the protagonist of
a very strong action that could win but you have a
very powerful antagonist so you're evenly matched
so from there on out it's really a fight to the
finish between the Sun and possibly the AI of the
father and this robot over the fate of the world
and
if the robot conclusively resolves his
dilemma which is the resolution in the end
and is kind of a desperate attempt
at sabotage to try to stop them
then the robot probably has to grow a lot to be
able to conclusively resolve that dilemma this
is like a desperate action and an emergency and
this is more like a comprehensive massive victory
that isn't going to backslide if he beats them
they're done they're gone they might be both dead
or they might be killed by the virus that they
were gonna but whatever it is he's really one
and he might still be a surfer on the beach at the
end you never know but so there's gonna have to be
you know it's the character it's
the completion of the character Arc
and a real fight to the finish and because the
antagonist is extremely powerful then it's not
a walk in the park at all to get from the point
of decision and action to the point of resolution
this is a declaration of war and it could
easily be a catastrophic loss for the automaton
but the automaton is growing changing and maybe
even still feeding on the original words of the
founding father when the AI said you can
do it you're you're a good creature you're
stronger than you know have trust in yourself
those might still be guiding words that help
the robot grow enough to defeat their treachery
and their power because even if the robot has
a great Victory five minutes after the
decision and action in the face of crisis
the Sun and possibly the AI or the father
May you know outweigh that with a really
treacherous powerful Act and like now our
automaton is seriously getting his butt kicked
and like it's you know it's the back and
forth as the automaton grows in capability
confidence and even sense of humanity like
a real conscience a real ability to see
that that's wrong and I don't need my
computer to be going this is 72 percent
this way this is 19. it's like no that's wrong
and there's no like it's just clear so that
the resolution if the automaton wins in the end
the this automaton is using some of the strengths
of the villain and of the corporation and
probably humans that work in there that he
has turned into allies like you know like you
and whose Army it needs to be like wickedly smart
incredibly forceful no half measures and you know
crushing truly treacherous lunatics who will stop
at nothing and who are immensely powerful so this
the weak little automaton that
was like disabled by the Sun and
wondering about things when it never
used to is now going to be by the end
a massively powerful Warrior whose self-confident
can make decisions has a good strong sense of
Ethics but will also burn this whole Factory
down and if a couple hundred workers die
in that it's going to save billions and
prevent this great evil from coming out
so capable of making hard choices great strength
of character Insight learned deviousness
learns how to fight dirty all of that whatever it
takes to conclusively resolve the dilemma that was
paralyzing him earlier on so he's a completely
different character at the end than he was
you know for a big chunk of his dilemma then
you have a powerful Dynamic ending you know
and it's possible he even converts the virus
that was going to kill a billion people into
I don't know a vaccine that you know ends
you know something on the Earth so that
because it was already too late to stop the
distribution of it but he can affect
the chemistry of it as it's being
distributed so that it's actually
ultra healthy for the people that
take it rather than they're going to
die in 19 hours or something like that
or it could you know it could be
a permanent cure for smallpox or
you know some of those things were already
cured but it could be something like that
and you know maybe the assistant of the sun maybe
when the sun said look when I do this last step to
you you really will be a human maybe the assistant
of the sun is able to do that step to him
so that we we see him on the beach and he
he'd still be this person of great power I
don't think you want to lose that but you know it
would be like you know seeing some really smart
powerful person on the beach
just hanging out having fun
so that you could see how that could be
one powerful resolution to this story
in a conclusive defeat of
the sun and the father's AI
and a prevention of this great catastrophe
and the destruction of this power grab
and once you can isolate and articulate
the resolution which we've only partially
articulated at this point it's pretty
tentative and flexible and fluid but
we can see it and you can see what it is so
that enables you to see the theme of the story
and the the best way to isolate and
articulate theme is to look at the resolution
and to look at the way in which the protagonist
resolves the dilemma so it's not what happens
but the way in which the protagonist does it
because there you have the completion of the
transformation of this character and so
this person who used to not trust their
own decision-making process and need
guidance from others and be unsure and
suspicious is now like I know what to do and I'm
you know unilaterally making all these decisions
and I'm using my power and it's just like he
might even be hearing the father's voice you
know the the untrue voice of the father but it's
still true for him you are a good creature use
your power don't let anybody tell you what to do
you don't need me to tell you what to do so that
he's like you know he's like coming into power
and if you look at the way in which he resolves
The dilemma you see that tremendous growth
of power and confidence and capability and
that's what the story is about thematically you
can you can look right there there's the theme
and the thing about working with theme in this
way is that you will have like a heart or gut
level understanding of it like you get it even
if you can't articulate it right away and that's
that's a really great place to be
because you really comprehend the theme
and the words you don't necessarily have the
words to be able to articulate it clearly yet
but that's okay because look at what the audience
when the audience sees that movie and they walk
out of the theater and they feel that greatness
of heart that this character imbued in them
that they're taking the theme home with them
they've got it they feel that greatness of
heart and that's what the the writer created
that crafted that the final effect is the
principle effect the ending is where the
power of the whole film comes together
it's like cracking a whip the tail end of it
breaks the speed of sound and that's what the
sound is and it's like being on a you know a a
chain one with skaters and everybody's holding
hands and the last person gets whipped way out
ahead the the power of the whole story is wrapped
up and delivered through the ending so you're
sculpting the mood that the audience goes home in
and they take the theme home with them and if you
do it powerfully enough you change their lives
they never look at the world the same after that
that greatness of heart that they got from this
story they they can always go back to that and
it's very powerful and like I remember when I
saw a Braveheart and I felt like that at the end
even though it was a weird sad ending I felt that
greatness of Heart of Wallace and I'm actually
reading Andrew Carnegie's autobiography now and
he's Scottish and grew up in Scotland and he said
they grew up on Wallace Wallace Robert the Bruce
who became king later and one other guy and they
said for a Scottish kid he was our hero and we
were like Wallace wouldn't have stood down now
like we like they become indomitable and it like
impacted their life for for the rest of his life
he was always like Wallace Bruce and whoever the
other guy was I can't remember but like you you
can really like shape somebody's approach to life
like I still remember when I saw the end of
Blade Runner it impacted me and it still does
and great movies with great endings can really
like permanently change how an audience thinks
and that's and they do that to varying degrees
all the way from zero to a hundred percent like
a hundred percent is like you never look
at the world in the way you used to again
and and then of course you know a lot of it is
just like you feel amazing for a couple days
or you feel beat up because it was a rough
ending but you learned something from it
but it's you know the ambition of a writer is
to permanently change how people think and you
just look at the resolution and look at the way
in which the protagonist resolves the dilemma
that's the theme look at training day the way in
which Jake resolves his dilemma is to absolutely
stand for his principles Antoine Fuqua the
director and David Ayers the writer both said
training day is about what if one man says no
and it's Jake's absolute ferocity I will not
stop I will not go away you're not getting
away with this no matter what that's what
that movie's about thematically you can feel
that coming out of the theater that's in you
mm-hmm so that's that's like a quick run
through really dilemma crisis decision and
action resolution but because different Enneagram
types will react to a dilemma in different ways
that helps a lot and you can see how the 36
dramatic situations just who's like throwing
gasoline on a fire like I could see some elements
and you throw ambition and Madness and conflict of
the god and rivalry of Superior and inferior
and the necessity of sacrificing loved ones
and you know all those types of things gave us
ideas to create the story it's just a set of
it's a brainstorming tool it's a suggestive
possibilities it triggers possibilities
and there's obviously a whole bunch more tools I
have seven tools all together but this is a good
look at the main thing I'm
doing here is as I start
with a raw idea I go right to dilemma and it's
almost like it's almost like the image of like
you might see like somebody in Africa carving
a drum and they're like working on the drum
but they're with their feet they're holding the
bottom of this thing that's going to become a
drum and they clamp it in and like I'm clamping on
to dilemma as I wrestle with the story so it's all
about the protagonist's dilemma as I invent the
story I'm focused on dilemma as I build the story
and that's a really fundamental skill in
using this tool and that dilemma is too
equally unacceptable Alternatives two equally
painful choices and it really does that Robbie
the robot like the person is paralyzed between
these two equally unacceptable alternatives for
the whole second act the paralysis is broken at
the point of Crisis but it's not until another
10 or 15 minutes of movie at the resolution
of the dilemma that the dilemma exclusively
conclusively resolved and so it constitutes three
quarters or more of the story and occupies the
full proportion of the story it's not a little
thing it's not a a minor problem that crops up
so yeah it's a
it's a real process that is extremely helpful in
essentially turning story into drama because
if it's just story then it's mere information
and it's not always as gripping as it could be
and a good strong dilemma can turn a good story
into a great drama in any genre like you
look at like Liar Liar with Jim Carrey
it's a fun whacked out comedy but it has a
dilemma of magnitude there's substance to
it Tutsi is a fun comedy but there's a lot of
substance and depth and a good strong dilemma
so it it can work in any genre and obviously
if it's a completely whacked out comedy then
there'll be less magnitude and more fun so it's
obviously you have a sense of how much of it you
need for a particular type of story but you know
the more familiar with it the more and the more
you understand the underlying principles behind
what makes the tool work then you can adjust the
tool as needed for each specific type of script
that has different demands and different tone
and different intensity and different impact on
the audience Jeff you've provided such valuable
information today and I love the way you you
question different story points if someone wants
to work with you what's the best way they can find
your teachings you know become a student of yours
well I have a couple different things I have
a book writing a great movie which will walk
you through all this and I build a real script in
the second half I have a three-month pre-recorded
training program where we build a real script
in three months and it's you work along with me
helping build the script and solving the
different puzzles involved as we build it
that's 65 hours of pre-recorded video and then
I have a two-year live training program where
we work five days a week about two and a half
hours a day and that three months is the first
part of that so you can get live intensive
training for two years and then we have a
subscription service where you can sign up and
pay a certain amount each month and have ongoing
access to live classes every week pre-recorded
trainings writings and so on that kind of thing
we can have a link below as well for viewers to
click on so if I want to take a class can I just
choose which one or do I is there a prerequisite
before taking some you can choose which one but
for the two-year the first part of that is the
three-month pre-recorded that's called course one
because course two is continuously ongoing so
like there's someone who just finished course
one yesterday who will be joining course two and
we're halfway through writing a romantic comedy
so he and because he's built a whole Thriller with
me in course one he's conversing with the tools
wrote the script based on the outline that we
created together so he can jump right in and
he has to learn about this particular story
but he's fluent enough with the tools that
he can just jump right in and not be going wait
what are you guys talking about he's like yeah
I know how to I know my way around and so it's
designed so that course one sets you up to jump
right into course two at any time and then I
do private Consulting as well which anybody can
get hold of me at script.kitchen just Jeff at
script.kitchen there's no.com it's dot kitchen
script.kitchen are most of your students working
adults taking this in addition to their foreign
they have more time but it's all across the
board and one of them is 15 living in Romania
they're like all over the world and all different
stages you know it's a commitment of time and
I'm not working with any of my individual students
own screenplays because that's too complicated
but we're all working together to build a script
and they're getting extensive hands-on experience
using all the tools in a collaborative way and
then once they're once they've been in course two
for long enough to feel like they really have
a handle on the tools then they build their
own script in front of the group to make sure
that they can really do this stuff themselves
and we come by every few days to check in on
how they're doing and they might want us to
brainstorm with them or you know they might
want to do it themselves I'd be like looking
at what they're doing what did you just solve
having them articulate their thought process
correcting them if they're doing
something technically slightly wrong
just to make sure that they really can do this
on their own and that then you know they'll be
extremely skilled seasoned and versatile as
dramatists and you could throw them a comedy
a Horror Story a sports drama anything and
they're like they know how to Grapple with
it make it work dramatically think through
the Deep aspects of the story dimensionalize
it build the characters make it fresh and
different and not predictable and cliche
you know I'm teaching some very powerful tools
and rigorous technique but I'm always emphasizing
you gotta have a real sense of
adventure you know it's storytelling
and the more craft you have the less you have
to make safe choices people make safe choices
as writers because they don't have the technique
to make a complex choice and make that work so
they make a safe choice because they know they
can make that work but I really teach Reckless
abandon like explosive creativity and like drive
off the get yourself in trouble if you're not in
over your head you're not doing your job right
people don't want to see the same lukewarm story
Trot it out again they want to see something
where they're going what was that and like
what just happened and where is it going now you
know it's that's the fun of being a writer and
you know so and the other thing is that
there's these seven tools but fully half
of what I'm teaching is just pure seed of the
pants storytelling you're just making stuff up
and that's huge the tools are just a part of
that and they can shape some of your processes
and make the things you choose work better and
more dramatic and more compelling and good tight
cause and effect so it moves well without being
bogged down by unnecessary stuff but if your
story is Bland and predictable then you could
just end up with well-structured crap so Mirror
Technique is not enough you really need explosive
creativity and Reckless abandon and just a refusal
to make safe choices and the refusal to knuckle
under the cliche and all that type of stuff
so it's part wild animal and it's part like
domesticated animal where you really can
make concise rigorous choices and technique
but the thing that you're applying that to
is you know like a 30-foot gorilla that'll rip
your arms off in a second you're working hard
to make the tools go to that the story is the
master you're just the person who's trying to
make it work dramatically so it can be
stage worthy on TV on film and theater.